let's do this let's jump to this
conspiracy theory sure this is this is
this is act like the good old days Tim
remember this those days this is what we
used to talk about good day this a lot
of people have been hitting me up for
this you ready yeah
ladies and gentlemen throughout the
night over the past two weeks explosions
have rocked major cities in the United
States leaving residents scared
terrified that the CIA has been leaving
caches of explosive devices for roughy
and children to detonate I I did a tweet
earlier I was just like I'm seeing too
much of this like who's hearing this is
going on I and to over 200 responses and
all of them are just like yeah fireworks
from the city late into the night and
I'm like usually doesn't that always
usually happen near the end of June
anyway no eating up to July no no no
this is weird okay
but I think I think I know what's going
on I I think you're right for those that
are familiar with the actual story
across the country there have been
massive complaints about fireworks in
every major city every single one even
some smaller towns from around like
eight till like 2:00 in the morning it's
just a constant fireworks and explosions
going off I saw people tweeting about
this and there's crazy conspiracy
theories first take a look at this in
2019 there were 27
fireworks complaints between June 1st
19th well its consists in 85 so
naturally that's a pretty big spike I
can tell you exactly and so so look it's
really look at this it's really started
my goodness you know to pick up around
the 10th yeah like I mean look it's they
said there was 27 in 2019 so we had 17
on the 4th then we had 11 34 and really
start to pick up now it's going crazy
right now we've got 1689 as of the 19th
I'm you know there are they just simple
noise complaints or fireworks yeah but
I've seen videos from Chicago of
shootouts that sound like firecrackers
yeah our works no but no no that's not
fireworks that people's are guns but
people can see the fireworks
like you can watch a video that's
legitimate fireworks listen alright the
solution is that the reason for this is
so incredibly obvious man yeah I can't
believe these people are actually trying
to argue what they're trying to argue
the reality is it's the CIA is obviously
planting fireworks in this neighborhoods
did you stabilize the black lives matter
movement by forcing people to endure
sleep deprivation that way they can't
properly organized in our constant under
stress and that way when they bring in
the real tanks every won't be too scared
and they won't know whether it's real
fireworks or guns I think you're
supposed to do that in the Alex Jones
voice people listen yeah in the
government so they know I'll give you
that I'll give you that I'll give you
the real explanation no I you told me
this earlier I agree with you ladies and
gentlemen why are there fireworks going
crazy here's my here's my theory
you see beginning of this month there
were nationwide riots you may have seen
that in the news if you recall maybe you
were paying attention the whole you may
have of June you may have also seen that
trucks were being stopped and raided and
people were eluding buildings and
stealing things what time of the year do
people buy fireworks for the 4th of July
I believe it's now Tim yes it's the
couple of weeks leading up to the 4th of
July they don't go out on July 3rd and
buy all their fireworks at once though
the people exist true the month before
they start going out and buying
fireworks yeah but Tim you say if if
that was the contributing factor to why
these at complaints are happening why
not the previous years because the
previous years didn't see mass looting
from people rioting trucks so here's
what I think happened a bunch of people
started jumping in trucks stealing boxes
and then found themselves in particular
areas with a ton of explosives
commercial-grade and said what do we do
with these sell them on the cheap to
local kids you know and now you are
seeing as following the end of the riots
lo and behold a massive increase in
fireworks you know going off yeah that
seems to be the most logical explanation
I'm seeing videos of people in New York
plan like firework wars now I'm not
gonna lie I've done it I've done it with
a helmet it's fun it's fun don't don't
try this at home people you know it's
not fun stop but do the kid my
neighborhood blows hand off
I hear stories about that all the time
you thought he thought it was like a
Corsica dynamite he thought it was a
roman candle oh so he lit it and went
like this boom in his hand just got
blown clean off and that's that yeah so
it was crazy the blood splatter
everywhere in don't mess around this
stuff yeah
you don't think keep your fingers yeah
you got to be smart yeah but that's
that's what I think we quite literally
have there was this woman from look at
this is crazy dude look how long this
thread is this dude's conspiracies like
check this out it is look at this mykes
he says fam does this gear in these
photos look similar to you he then shows
what appears to be a random photo of
which a firefighters and their babies
isn't Father's Day yesterday and then he
shows does you treat him with those he
you spoil if you spoil him now he wants
a piece of that pie oh he's looking for
the cookies go back to the display go
back to the producer rebels all right
check it out he says in this tweet
doesn't this gear look in these photos
look similar to you in this photo
somebody is selling a bunch of fireworks
right
what's this strap right here the back
that's a back exactly that's the back to
back back and so look what he does he
then shows this where you've got
firefighters with suspenders at all this
is the nature of conspiracy insanity
this dude is listener that's bad look at
look how crazy this is this was tweeted
out by the woman who wrote the 16:19
project oh my god the New York Times
writer they show this video for the
folks who didn't see it's about
apparently some firefighters had a
fountain firework yeah those are yeah
and he claims that's proof the
government is doing it what he says the
FDNY got caught letting off illegal
fireworks like bro there's a big
difference between our you know
commercial grade mortar shell versions
right and a little
you know fountain firework yeah that's
probably the the peak there - let's
finish like this my neighbors and I
believe this is part of a coordinated
attack on black and brown communities by
government forces and attack meant to
disorient and destabilize the black
lives matter movement and I think it's
called paranoid delusional hitting up
everybody everyone that lives around
there is getting hit yep it's like no I
don't get it dude that's a stretch
reporting from Brooklyn there was at
another night of extremely loud
fireworks these people have lost the
plot man I agree they're they're
completely out of it what do we have
here we got two more interesting some
things about these fireworks LAPD is
telling people that email about the
fireworks their ability to deal with
them has been postponed to the protests
they're trying to get people angry at
the protesters about this see there's
always some kind of conspiracy they're
trying to you know what you know there
and he's claiming and this he's claiming
that the NYPD is pulling a Chancellor
sutler right if you guys have seen V for
Vendetta right I'm sure this guy is
claiming that the police had a meeting
he doesn't literally say this but he's
insinuating this is what happened that
the chief of police ghost all these cops
and says I want fireworks on every
street corner
I want explosions in the middle of the
night I want these people to remember
why they need us yeah yeah that's where
the logic is going on the NYPD has
dropped caches of fireworks for young
people to find to blow up in the middle
of the night to shock people and scare
them into realizing they need black and
brown people yes sorry I already called
you out on it
Democrats you're the ones that are
basically but they don't have a
Chancellor sutler but that's what it
feels like they're they're like covet 19
you need juice
you need a thou'rt Arianism and then all
the riots like police state can
understand what we do anymore
i tweeted this clip out yeah all right
so go to go to twitter.com slash tim
cast look at this the clip i tweeted
it's from V for Vendetta and I'll tell
you what the craziest thing is I didn't
even notice this at first Chancellor
sutler is like the bad guy right he's
like the fascist dictator and he tells
them what they want what they need to do
is like I want story to story coverage I
want people to be scared so they were
I want them reminded why they need us he
wants people to be scared and begging
for the government safety and then the
first thing they show is a TV screen
that says America's second civil war
still going yeah and she's like the
civil war in America rages on
you know housing turmoil in the middle
and in the Midwest and I was like well
you were watching it and I was like holy
cow what it's a sign they're predicting
the second Civil War but but there's
actually some other stuff in this that's
really amazing they then show I think
it's someone saying a new pandemic and
then the guy it was a guy in a barn he
goes do you believe this and I was like
no I really happening are we in a movie
yeah all right Everett ladies and
gentlemen have you seen this meme ladies
and gentlemen have you seen this meme go
on Google type in any three-digit number
beginning with the number one and then
followed by new cases no it doesn't have
to have a 1 in it it can be any three it
has to begin with the number one huh I
tried all three I didn't I didn't know
that rule and I was doing all different
combinations there's numbers there's no
there's no web there's nothing for zero
one two it has to start with a number
one or or two no no I mean it's alright
any any number greater than one if yes a
really funny point someone said I'm a
programmer so I tried zero zero one it
didn't work that's a good point we get
it you're a programmer you think I said
the box but if you if you take any
number from 100 up to 999 you will find
every single number comes up yep every
single one I tried for a little while I
was like I can't believe this is working
so I tried 100 101 102 103 104 and you
put you know 101 new cases boom I tried
999 boom I tried 6xx boom Oh two three
two two three seven 349 boom boom boom
boom they'll come up I did this random
one it was like eight three I forget
that the combo and it was like the angel
number and I was like wait what is this
what yeah weird it was like Kovac Kovac
covent the angel number
so first I'm not alleging any conspiracy
craziness with this meme or whatever it
is you think Oh buds real still
there's I think it's certainly I think
people panicked for sure okay I think
they went nuts and they were like
screeching and freaking out for sure
okay but there's a there is a simple
explanation for it you'll notice a lot
of these places are in foreign countries
when you type in like you know 371 it
might say like yeah Ukraine poll showed
up but there's also different different
states for sure always a different
school behind small town so I think the
real issue here is that when you factor
in the entire planet was hit by this
pandemic for the most part you know
Google search is gonna find you any
story good yeah odds are good and we're
talking about only a thousand different
numbers out of three months of every
city and every country in the world so
it is interesting but I but while I
don't think it's a grand conspiracy
because no one's coordinating every
single website to produce numbers like
this right it just reminds me of that
scene where the guys like he no longer
believes it he's in the bar and he looks
the press and he's like do you believe
this bollocks actually he says are you
serious or do you believe it there's a
swear in there yeah what it reminds me
if I want to be accurate all right
yeah trying to be factual it reminds me
of all the people who are saying I don't
believe this anymore
right I just don't believe it yeah I
felt like we were in a movie when I saw
that yes like that's us happening so is
it the apocalypse or are we being
tricked by the fascists who are trying
to remind us why we need them so is that
the idea that like they're trying to
make everything crazy so that we long
for the days before Trump maybe the
normalcy that Joe Budden brings the
sweet sweet sound of Joe Biden Christmas
right behind you and whispering in your
ears yep
whispering sweet sweet you know no
things like that's what I want things to
come back I don't want China to make our
medicine like we are like you know in
their shadow right now they make
everything for us and it's like what
happened to the days of American made
being like the quality product like
those garbage products yeah those those
days don't exist anymore it's like what
why can't we bring that back let's make
quality stuff let's appreciate quality
over throw away everything which is what
we live in the environment the society
that we live
it's like I just tossed this whatever I
just get a new one or get something
really quality something really nice
that lasts for a long time that you can
fix bring factories back let's like it's
basically just ruining the the profits
of the the corporation since like boohoo
sorry corporations they're the ones who
probably hate Trump the most
it's a weird extraction of resources you
end up with big corporations that get us
Americans to pay Chinese labor which
stays in China yeah and then that money
goes to the the bigwigs and that creates
extreme wealth disparity here in America
and this is the craziest thing that you
have the left arguing that wealth
disparity is bad and that Trump is bad
and it's like but you realize if Trump
brings those jobs back right it will
normalize they'll bring the middle class
back exactly so it'll actually make a
lot of things more expensive for us here
in America what which will make you
appreciate the item more people spend a
thousand bucks on their phone and they
cherish their phone yeah it's like okay
you realize they break the screens all
the time too
okay well whatever you know you get my
point though right it's like you know
people spend money spend a lot of money
on is the thing they're like oh I'm
gonna cherish this yeah but everything
else is throw away everything like our
like bridges everything or their toilets
yeah you think about that and you're
like whatever but you can go buy a new
toilet imagine whatever imagine if it
was five bucks to flush your toilet
people would probably
they'd be like I'm gonna hold it in
until the very last minute that when I
just have one big detonation but because
it's free that uh dude look bowel
movements are funny there will come a
time in the future where like you're
gonna be an old man and you're gonna
have like a little little kid he's gonna
be like grandpa Adam can you tell me
about how you used to flush fresh water
down the toilet and you're gonna go okay
we used to flush it down the toilet you
know now it's 50 bucks a gallon yeah
that's what the futures gonna be lush
water it's gonna be the the water yeah
yep yeah you need water for your cities
to operate you know and people don't
realize that fresh water isn't you open
you turn the sink on for fresh water
like Laura how did grow how did the you
know Rome empire spread because they had
roads and aqueducts
well mostly roads but it was like they
had aqueducts why their cities worked
yep they had society so if you don't
want these things go live in the middle
of the woods see how long you'll allow
these privileged people go to the city
like they're in Chad's and they'll have
flushable toilet I know exactly
turn off the toilet see how long they
last well no they have didn't have like
we're dividing line of porta-potties
well in Chicago they were pooping in a
tent and I don't mean in a bucket
content I mean they literally were
pooping in attack protect yeah you know
what you know man
they proposed humanure in chess that's
that doesn't work if you someone
responded with it doesn't work because
human waste is too acidic yeah yeah
there's actually there's certain diets
if you are a hundred percent perfect on
your diet I believe it's like a 100%
plant-based right no none grass yeah
basically like I mean I'm not even that
far you know my poops probably not good
for manure but it's not good you can
they were proposing it worked for da
Matt Damon on Mars though yeah we all
learned something well so potatoes grow
the idea maybe a movie I'm not sure in
the chest in that could you imagine this
in a park in Seattle in a major city
spread and poop a bunch of left-wing
activists all are squatting in a field
taking dumps just out in the open
do you think they were there Gardens do
you think they would segregate the poop
maintained like this is white poop the
white garden well done no whoa whoa they
would expect they would expect the
racial people in their own gardens to
poop so yes the poop would be segregated
a segregated poop I wonder I wonder this
is the world we're living in now could
you imagine if they accidentally
discovered a racial disparity and the
manure value of human waste oh my gosh
like by accidentally segregating the
races we've determined that Latinos in
fact have the most potent fertilizer
poop accidental like who nobody knew how
did that happen
and they do a bunch of controls no but
they were gonna want to poop in fields
and that's that's the crazy thing is
that they don't really don't understand
none of you know what you know it's
crazy to me
none of them
understand - that's a thousand years ago
400 years ago you think most people it
seen a dead body
no yeah definitely for sure apps today I
have I mean in real life or fancy doc
yes you've worked in a hospital so I
mean the answer to yes for that in
people who work in hospital is gonna
skyrocket but in real regular non
hospital world how many people actually
saw okay yeah you know they those those
are those are not the majority of people
we're talking about the majority of I'm
talking about yes 10 year-old kid I
didn't want to say normies does that
feel awfully derogatory but 10 year-old
kid in the year like 16 something yeah
in the colonies walking down and there's
like old man Jenkins just flump Tovar
dead and bloated yep and it's like you
know people die uh mr. Jenkins had
babies - you know and he owed me a
nickel yep today people do but I think
the overall majority of these privileged
people like Chaz have never they
probably never even seen anybody get a
boo-boo you know we'll have now well now
they have oh that's right yeah people
getting shot my skateboard did more
damage to my ankle than that guy yeah
yeah that's funny so Adam was skating
and he keeps hitting the same spot in
his on his ankle ripping it open it's
the truth and blood is pouring out all
over his shoe and sock and I'm like dude
wrap it up what did i do though you just
kept skating but I landed it yeah I was
like no no I gotta land this trick I was
like take a picture of it man yeah but
what's funny is there was more blood
there then when the guy in the in the
Chad's got hit with her with a foam
bullet and it gave him an abrasion and
so he's like crying and they're like
they're putting a tourniquet on his leg
yeah I don't want to lose my leg and
they were like we got to stop the
bleeding don't is like dude it was a
minor minor abrasion like crazy you were
bleeding like crazy your sock is soaking
something blood and you were he's washed
it off it was really bad oh yeah you got
a rapper I cleaned it I you know I took
care of my but it's funny that like what
will go out skating you'll whack your
ankle go oh no not again in blood that's
pouring out and you keep skating yeah
the kids and the Chaz are like it I got
I got an abrasion quick tourniquet put
the gauze on it quick you're gonna be
fine dude you're gonna be fine hang in
there I think we were talking about this
earlier just like we really we really
have a whole this this kid is going not
gonna go settle things it's your fault
you spoil him no he's bored that the cat
is no they're fighting no no no he's
just slash up the tissue paper well he
just chased her out of the room Betsy
yeah well that's cats for you yes
they're fighting what are we talking
about what are we told ya the lost our
universe the lost generation of people
who will never be able to survive on
their own I think it was funny because
somebody mentioned yeah like I was
talking about how Millennials can't
survive you put me the middle of the
woods and a lot like a real panic attack
yeah and then somebody something like
somebody tweeted at me like Tim Poole
thinks he could survive on the work in
the woods lmao oh I didn't say that like
where'd you get that information I
didn't I didn't say like them that's
that emotional trigger that I'm
emotionally triggered I immediately have
to degrade you and bring you down and it
doesn't even have to be relevant I just
need to attack you because I'll tell you
what attacked my emotional Center I'll
tell you I'll tell you one thing happens
all the time
if you took me and one of these like
Chaz s uw's and put em in the woods okay
there's a lot of circumstances in which
I would be more likely to survive
because you'd eat them no wait I would
be I would I would be more hardened and
like not scared or panicky I wouldn't be
demanding I'd be responsible I would you
know first try and figure out shelter
while you're vegans are grass-fed so
they taste better yeah that's a good
point
but I was gonna say in it you know these
people have no idea these people have no
idea how to deal with animals right yeah
that's true what do you do when you
encounter a mountain lion do you know
man
I probably make yourself as big as
possible and make a lot of noise yes
that is correct
there was there was a recent thread
where like some cops said slowly back
away and that's a mistake you need to
make them feel like they're gonna get
into a fight and they don't want to
right now what do you do when you
encounter a black bear run faster than
the scrawny jazz person and that's and
that's where I live I'd be like darting
and
be like wait wait how about your bear
food buddy not sticking around no way so
those things can climb fast bear you
can't climb up a tree those things will
climb up if they want you
black bears you have to fight that's I I
could be wrong but don't don't act like
I'm not I'm not you know that what's his
name Bear Grylls during drinking guy I'm
not him
yeah guns aren't always even for hunting
there's this thing called self-defense I
don't know if you've heard of this but
there's animals that live in the world
that will eat jeez these people listen
they would see a mountain lion these
people would see a mountain lion yeah
and they would scream and run right and
even a but when you do that with a mark
Murray the mountain line immediately
charges he's like oh pray they're
running yeah so you look them in the
eyes and you make yourself big and huge
come on let's do the horns
that's what I would do and then rip my
shirt off they don't I don't know yeah
start waving it around in the air how
many of these people graduates all right
how many of these chairs people do you
think I've ever heard the sound of a
gunshot I don't know the John Brown Gun
Club guys cuz definitely yeah as I think
about myself it's like you would never
have expected someone like me to have
heard gunshots and yet I've heard
gunshots a lot in my life
Chicago Chicago New York yeah hi autumn
are this when we were in Baltimore at
the riots it's like we've you know I've
been in situations where I've seen this
stuff it's like you were two people but
you think about them it's like ah
they're a bunch of sjw's but you know
what I don't know I don't think it's all
true you know there's there's definitely
some hardened people over there but even
the John Brown gun club people are like
they're definitely better than most of
the the far left E's who are like really
scrawny frail eating poor diets and are
kind of messed up in the head yeah like
at least they understand the basics of
like using guns and I'll admit like I'm
not there they're better than me and all
that stuff for sure yeah but I've
actually watched videos of these guys
and they are still like there's they
no LARPing yeah kind just playing the
part like the guy listen what you know
why it is that they're more scared of
right-wing terror than left-wing terror
why because the left-wing terrorists who
have tried are just pathetic
yeah absolutely pathetic that's a good
point the dude who went to the ice
facility will Evan Williams Vance
Bronson Trevor and was like it's it's
like this I was gonna say something
funny but really offensive all stop
saying it good for you
it's uh I really want to make the job I
can't do it no don't do it no I can't
you do I was gonna say you know there's
there's there's I really want to say
there's you know the cops took Chaz
again they went back to the precinct
they marched through no one did a thing
they walked right in right walked into
the precinct there was people like they
went back in and now they're I don't
know if they're still there I don't know
if they were checking out the scene but
videos were flying around that okay yep
they retook it and no one did a thing
you have these like extremists they call
them far-right I don't know Sara Lee
know what that means because it's alt
left no I'm talking about like the
Church shootings and New Zealand stuff
like that they say it's like
everything's right-wing or whatever so I
but but anyway they fear these people
because they're effective and I'm not
saying this is this is horrifying about
it that when these these lunatics try
you know decide to engage in some kind
of terrorist activity they succeed and
it's it's it's really scared it's a good
point it's a good vanspronsen guy showed
up staggered like a [ __ ] throwing
firebombs randomly and then he got melee
got shot and killed right like he has no
right it's an it's like an emotional
attack versus like a logical attack
they're both attacks and are not it's
it's an issue of capability right though
the the left like an tyfa are pathetic
scrawny losers okay like come on man
watch the video the proud boys vs.
antipático when he winds the punch up
and smacks yeah it's like watching Mike
Tyson box a three-year-old yeah
seriously you know he walks up and he's
like I'm gonna give you a good punching
Bowman and the kid goes flying 20 feet
he's he's training again oh yeah dude
the Beast
yeah dude for sure he's still a beast I
saw a video his training video is like
I would I don't want to ever be even
near your punch yeah when he punches
like hammers man but the point is that
like when you when you end up with
whatever the right is you have masculine
aggressive tactful strategic and the
further you go left you get unhinged
whiny and like not fairly well
thought-out at all yeah and so we were
talking about yesterday at the at the
restaurant when we were talking about I
said it I was like this is this is
basically what you get when you you know
it inverts into the unbalance between
the matriarchy and the patriarchy and
they're like bring the patriarchy down
and now we have all these people that
don't have dads they don't have a father
figure
and they're they're raised by their
mothers which is you know spin in the
other way and so they're seeking
approval for by any means necessary what
we feels like you're about to add
something but you know you know I'm
saying it's like so we're seeing it
these all these people that are out
there they they I I'm just making a huge
assumption here that they don't have a
solid father figure showing being like
no that is not acceptable in discipline
instead of a mother were that you don't
wanna wants to give you everything and
be the mother figure the clothes the
traditional mother figure I guess I'm
saying you know you see that video of
it's the the black dude punches the
mesas employee have you seen I have seen
it I don't know much about it so other
than that one video that this video goes
viral it's manned this this black dude
walks up to a white dude punches him in
the face and then you know the heat that
they claim that the white dude called
him the N word right and it's funny like
as if that would justify an assault the
police should go and rest these guys
right but in the video that the the the
the dude who's beating on the maces
employee who says don't touch me don't
touch me and what's the maces employee
say I'm sorry I'm sorry as he cowers on
the ground and rolls around and I'm like
that men on the floor is truly pathetic
now think about that dude raising kids
yeah and you can talk about a good a
good father figure someone who's strong
determined disciplined and can instill
what is acceptable unacceptable yeah
that dude I'm sorry would be a terrible
father
what would his kids be like to cower on
the ground I don't know saying I'm sorry
over and over again as someone assaulted
you for no reason I'm sorry I'm sorry
that's one of my favorite things about
the ancient Egyptians they're a lot of
their texts showed that there's such
beauty in the balance of the masculine
and the feminine and it's like we have
no balance yeah anymore
the society is all unbalanced it's all
feminine oh no no no it's on either side
it that's what I'm seeing you have to
pick a side on every subject anyone
brings up at all there's either this
side or this side and if you're over
here and they're over here
they hate you you're a butt off I don't
care I don't want it I don't want to
even hear your argument or watch
whatever proof you think we're going to
bring up but I'm saying like in terms of
masculine and feminine okay our society
is just all feminine so masculine we've
talked about this earlier along here I'm
here proven otherwise baby masculine is
the determination the risk-taking the
striving to be more to be better yeah
and also to protect and build that's you
man and you you are you showed me that
you need to you need to have that that
drive to further yourself all right
right femme femininity okay is
protection right mitigating risk caring
healing yes so what is our society right
now risk is bad anything that could be
harmful must be banned it is all toxic
femininity exactly masculinity is gone
but they're trying to erase it
completely it mostly is they're trying
to sway I there are people that are
fighting it I am one of them just wait
until they announce NFL has to be gender
diversified that's not gonna fly I
disagree okay
look at look at the latest video games
that have come out and how they force
this culture on people what they like it
or not last of us - yeah for example
yeah and you know and I've talked to a
friend of mine who said it's a
masterpiece and I'm like is it though
III I tweeted this out and I'm reading
all these I'm not playing the game I
have zero interest in playing the game
but it from what I'm finding it's that
they are trying to they're it's
basically the character character of all
the SJW believed right that the real
life is like that
men talk like what what they say behind
closed doors and and it's like they're
shoving it down your throat and making
it this whole thing and it's like oh my
gosh I don't want that I don't want to
hear what you think the world is like
because that's not what reality is like
that's what you want reality to be like
because that justifies the way you're
acting how many how many people in this
country are trans I don't know this
number it's something like point zero
zero four percent they're really small
number yeah it might it might actually
be higher than most people realize but
it's that's fine be trans like gray
doesn't bother me that that's not you my
life the issue is that they're one of
the reasons I think that we will come to
a point where football is overtly SJW
okay like we're already seeing now the
guy like Colin Kaepernick is being you
know floated again they're gonna bring
them back for a kneeling and black lives
matter and all the stuff but the last of
us to has a trans sex scene alright yeah
that doesn't speak to ninety nine point
nine eight percent of the population of
this country agreed I'm not saying I
care I really I really don't I really
honestly don't care I think it's fine if
they wanted to do it that's their choice
of a game right and people really do
like the game look I talked to I was
talking to some guy recently who said he
really loved the game that's why my
point is not that is anything wrong with
that
right it's that it's not it's certainly
not catering to a mass market right so
what would happen then if this point
zero two percent of people said women
should be in them in the NFL what's
going to stop them from forcing women to
be in the NBA the NFL and the in the MLB
and all that stuff it's like this whole
battle with you know trans athletes it's
like it's it's basically taking women's
achievements and just pooping all over
them basically like now you know this
this person identifies as well they're
winning so they're winning I I was a
woman I'd be upset about it yeah and and
guess what when they burned down the
businesses of a lot of these restaurants
where those owners say well I appreciate
the movement because they know if they
speak up they will come back there's a
woman right now who's working with the
police because they burned out and they
looted her bakery and they're sending
her death threats now for working with
the cops they're saying be a happy
little victim and you take what you get
period and they're winning
we thought it was going away with kovat
and now it's come back so intense it's
amazing how much they have gained with
knocking down statues check this out
three guys apparently got arrested for
vandalizing a black lives matter mural
of some sort okay I got arrested
how many people have torn down statues
of founding fathers and nothing's
happened that's crazy
how many people got arrested for rioting
in Fort Worth and were released the
rioting charges dropped how many people
in New York were arrested during the
protest for George Floyd and were
released and all charges dropped and how
many people got tickets for trying to go
to church they are winning they're
taking it over and they are going to
force football to do this stuff too and
NASCAR and and Major League Baseball and
it is gonna be completely unrecognizable
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you